good morning John do you know what life
is question is always fascinating me I
mean at first it seems like kind of a
simple question like not dead you're
live pretty big difference there when
you're dead you're stinky
you're decomposing you turn and you stop
move everybody's very clear but if you
think about it for a long time it's not
whether or not I'm alive or dead it's
whether or not a virus is ever alive or
whether or not a computer virus is ever
alive what about Johnny five and those
little things from batteries not
included and if you weren't alive in the
80s what about Gladys if we don't have a
definition how will we know when we've
created something that's a lot and
doesn't really matter and is this all
just pseudo-intellectual navel-gazing
navel-gazing is a weird term staring
into your belly whoa what is that so
when I asked on Twitter I got some funny
answers but mostly what I got was a list
of criteria which will be used to be
wooded being taught in schools right now
move respire sense reproduce excrete and
nourish first that is the list of
criteria it is not a definition second
that list of criteria seems a little bit
unnecessarily restrictive to me like
Lieutenant Commander data if you are
Star Trek nerd he doesn't respire he
doesn't grow he doesn't reproduce
nonetheless he is alive he's more than a
life he's sentient so my personal
definition this is the one that I've
come up with life once
if thing X requires thing Y in order to
continue it's exist and thing X shows
attempts to acquire thing wide thing X
apparently wanting thing Y is alive a
side note if one thing is in fact the
fundamental attribute of what makes
things alive like it goes a long way to
explaining why sure humans never seem to
stop wanting I mean even if you got like
twenty thingamabobs
you got whosits and whatsits school or
still oh I'm not embarrassments Aparna
we want more with the definition of want
is that it's fairly easy to create a
computer program that wants some like
Google search but for example once to
seek out and search information and send
it back but does that make Google
software a lot but beyond the biological
definitions my favorite definition of
life is Schrodinger's and yes
Schrodinger the Duke cattle entropy is a
physical measurable physical quantity
quality like mass or heat you know and
it's a measurement of this organization
as your entropy goes up you become less
organized my body right here from the
strands of DNA
and the cells in my feet to my
delightfully tousled mop of hair is an
extremely organized really organ just
tremendous amount of organization up the
second law of thermodynamics states that
entropy must as a rule increase and the
disorder of the universe will forever
increase what then is this this
magnificent near-perfect amazingly
organized meat that contains me ginger
said basically I'm paraphrase
is any system that continuously
decreases its own entropy using energy
around it basically Schrodinger took a
fundamental philosophical question and
answered it with an equation which is
just a maze but if life organizes itself
using energy then Schrodinger's
definition kinda is just as bad as mine
when it comes to Google though Google no
doubt was created by man
it currently on its own organizes itself
using the energy that it it has which is
the power from the power grist so is
Google alive I'm going to break some
rules here and venture a cautious yes
and you are welcome to comment on my
idiocy in the comments and there are
some people who say that they value all
individual living organisms just because
they are alive to those people I say you
don't really believe that I made a point
this morning to not brush my teeth
how is that really but because I didn't
brush my teeth today there are
approximately a hundred billion living
organisms in my mouth right the question
becomes do all those organisms have
value and if they do that I do I have a
responsibility not to kill all of them
the answer is no they don't have value
and I don't care if they live or die my
breath stinky and neither do you at
least I hope because you also kill
billions of them every single day John I
will see you on Wednesday the only thing
you've managed to break so far is my
heart